cameron khan baby so the trailer to
avatar 2 avatar the way of water has hit
the internet i actually saw it at
cinemacon cinemacon was amazing because
i was hanging out with my old boss like
from the movie theater for my days as a
projectionist easily the best boss i've
ever had he goes to cinemacon every year
he's told me for years that i should go
to cinemacon we were just two dudes
hanging out for the sake of friendship
and love of james cameron point is the
story time leading up to the trailer
we're going into the disney presentation
and they were like oh get your 3d
glasses before you go in
you know for something we were like
cameron khan cameron
we were just being dorks about it anyhow
at the end of the whole disney thing we
saw the trailer for avatar too were we
hoping for like 15 minutes of footage
like avatar day back in 2009 yeah but
we're just we're greedy like that we
know that and man this trailer
looks amazing just visually speaking but
it was the underwater scenes one in
particular where i was like okay so you
can't say james cameron doesn't make
good on his promises everyone aquaman
the movie came out i guess james cameron
said something along the lines of
it wouldn't really look like that
underwater he's like oh can you do
better okay oh god you did there's
something about that scene that just
looks like national geographic footage
of the navi underwater smiling living
their best life in fact if this whole
thing is a troll and years down the line
james cameron's like yeah i actually
found an alien world and all this is
actually real footage of them underwater
i'd be like
i'm not too surprised that just looks
amazing and i've seen it on youtube i've
seen it on the big screen in 3d on the
big screen in 3d is 3d tech like it's
like avatar was the rise of 3d tech and
3d tech in terms of entertainment's just
kind of fallen by the wayside avatar the
way of water is one of those movies
coming out where i'm like i'm looking
forward to watching a movie in 3d
for the first time in
ever i just james cameron's the only one
who could be like yeah i'm gonna do it
in 3d i'm gonna do it right and i feel
like it's justified so looking at the
trailer another thing i like about this
trailer is it's a teaser trailer it
doesn't give away much some great
visuals some epic avatar musical score
swelling and that's what you get but if
i'm looking at the teaser trailer it
looks like
they learned
[Laughter]
earth [ __ ] have learned from their last
confrontation they used to have these
big mech warrior things they're like all
right that's how we fight the navi turns
out aywah does not like that and they
were like well a marine in an avatar
body is truly a potent mix we'll go
ahead and take a page from that book and
make our own avatar bodies with marines
in them and we'll fight the other na'vi
what it looks like anyway you know just
from the visuals and
no real plot points given in the teaser
trailer because let's face it this
trailer really is a showcase of the tech
where james cameron's like okay this is
what it looks like 13 years since the
first movie 10 years of delays since the
second movie was initially supposed to
come out let's face it this is james
cameron we're talking about here 10
years of delays to us is just 10 years
of opportunity for him opportunity to
refine the tech so this trailer had to
justify this movie being pushed back so
much technologically speaking looks
pretty great james cameron's just one of
those directors that when he creates a
world
it just pulls me into it you know to a
degree that not a lot of directors can
do i mean i walked out of avatar in 2009
i was like that was magical all these
years later
i ain't taking it back
what avatar's [ __ ] cool i get lost in
the world is that the uncool thing to
say in a youtube video absolutely
don't care funny thing is when they
showed the trailer at cinemacon they
were like okay so this trailer is going
to play for a week exclusively on doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
then a week later it'll come online
apparently by a week they meant weekends
fine for me i get to get this video up
earlier in the week no problem but this
trailer for avatar the way of water
teaser trailer how teaser trailers
should tease your trailer avatar being
heavily built on the visuals you see the
advancement of tech you see how the
visuals look and it looks amazing and i
for one can't wait to see it it's like
this trailer makes it real when i saw
the trailer it was like so this is
coming out this year it's funny it's the
cinematic scope of the world is just
different now it's very much mcu
superhero movies the spearhead that they
were not back in 2009. do people care as
much about avatar these days as they did
back in the table time will tell but as
for me i still love avatar still a huge
james cameron fans of avatar the way of
water trailer it hit me and those who
know know when they see it in this
trailer the rule of cinema
never bet against cameron all right so
the teaser trailer to avatar the way of
water have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you